- [Narrator] This satellite
image shows a field
outside the eastern
Ukrainian town of Vuhledar,
littered with destroyed
tanks and infantry vehicles.
Ukrainian and Western officials
say this is the results
of a battle which has already cost Russia
dozens of military vehicles
and hundreds of troops
since February.
The coal mining town in
Ukraine became a new focus
of Russia's offensive due
to a strategic location.
From here, Ukrainian forces
can target rail lines
linking Russian-occupied Donetsk
to the Crimean Peninsula,
a major base for Moscow's operations.
The Wall Street Journal
analyzed videos taken
within two miles of Vuhledar,
and we spoke to British and
American military experts
to find out what this offensive
reveals about the state
of Russia's army a year into the war.
In late February, Ukraine's
Army shared this video
of an intersection just outside Vuhledar.
Kyiv says it shows a
Russian armored vehicle
running over a landmine.
The area, where at least
seven other vehicles appear
to have been damaged, looks
like what military experts call
a choke point.
As the video shows,
Russian troops strove down
a narrow route to the intersection,
making them easy targets for
mines and Ukrainian fire.
Despite the obvious dangers,
Russian tanks seem to roll
onto the same trap again,
and again, as we see in another
video released a week later.
Ukrainian soldiers on the front lines say
Russian forces kept making similar moves.
(soldier speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] Military experts
who watched these videos
say this shows that Russian
troops received orders
from the top, and most likely
didn't have the autonomy
to adjust to the situation on the ground.
And that is an extreme example
of how Russia's military
didn't adapt from the old
command and control system
from the Soviet's era.
Another issue the analyst pointed out
is that it appears the area
wasn't cleared of mines
before the tanks moved forward.
Soldiers would normally use
smoke to cover themselves
from enemy shells, but videos
show it didn't happen here.
Military analysts say one reason
could be the poor training
of recently-mobilized Russian soldiers.
Russia's army has paid a high price
for the decisions in Vuhledar.
Ukraine said it destroyed
at least 30 tanks
and infantry-fighting vehicles
within 10 days in February.
(weapon firing)
- The whole Russian brigade
was effectively annihilated
or destroyed.
They lost nearly 1,000, or
over 1,000 people in two days.
- [Narrator] Russia's Defense
Ministry didn't respond
to the Journal's questions
on the losses in Vuhledar,
but its spokespeople have
repeatedly claimed successes
against Kyiv's forces in
parts of southeastern Ukraine.
(soldier speaking foreign language)
(weapon firing)
Some experts believe Russia's
hasty offensive in Vuhledar
could be due to the Kremlin's
desire to show results
after months without major victories.
Western officials say the
Russian army has been plagued
by chronic issues such as an
ineffective command structure,
and poor training since
the start of the war.
And the setbacks in
Vuhledar suggest the issues
haven't been resolved on the battlefield.
One military expert said
Vuhledar shows a high price
the Kremlin is willing to pay.
Russia hopes to overcome
Ukraine's resistance
with more soldiers and military hardware
before Western weapons arrive
to help the Ukrainians.